Speaker 1: Marjorie Taylor GREENE and Lauren
Boebert, two dangerously delusional members of
Congress got into a verbal fight in the women's
bathroom when dim witted dunce clashes with
brainless buffoon. This is what you get. It is
being reported by The Daily Beast and summarized
by LGBTQ Nation. Marjorie Taylor GREENE and
Lauren Boebert allegedly got into a screaming
match in the women's restroom. Both GREENE and
Boebert have said transwomen are a threat to cis
women in public restrooms and locker rooms. But
it appears the real aggression in the women's
room writes This article is coming from them.
The too far right anti LGBTQ plus extremists
reportedly got into a shouting fight January
3rd just as Congress was getting ready to vote
for Speaker of the House, according to several
unnamed sources who spoke to The Daily Beast.
During the 15 votes that lasted for an entire
week. You might remember that Boebert and some
others were trying to prevent Kevin McCarthy from
being speaker. GREENE is a member of that same
wing, sometimes known as the Freedom Caucus, but
she ended up siding with McCarthy, as we now know.
The article goes on to say, According to one
source, GREENE was exiting a stall when she
confronted Boebert about the latter's plan to
thwart McCarthy's election. GREENE allegedly
accused Boebert of taking money from McCarthy
for her campaign, but not showing loyalty. Now,
she allegedly asked you were okay taking millions
of dollars from McCarthy, but you refused to vote
for him for speaker. Lauren GREENE questioned
Baba's loyalty to McCarthy, and after words were
exchanged, Boebert stormed out. That's when
Lauren said, Don't be ugly. Before Boebert,
quote, ran out like a little schoolgirl. When
questioned about the altercation, Boebert said,
See you later by. GREENE hasn't commented either.
Congresswoman Debbie Dingell. Dingell Dingell was
reportedly in the restroom when this happened,
but she's not talking about it. What happens
in the ladies room stays in the ladies room.
This is this is part of this splintering of
the Republican Party. I know I've said it before.
I know apologies for those who have heard this,
but you originally had Republicans pro
and anti-Trump people like, you know,
Mitt Romney in the anti-Trump camp. You now still
have the anti-Trump Republicans, but you have MAGA
or buffoonery. Call it whatever you want.
Call it peaches for all I care to quote Trump.
You now have maga subdividing and splintering.
And of course, the dream scenario would be that
they splinter themselves into oblivion. Whether
it's going to happen or not, we just don't yet
know. But Lauren Boebert and Marjorie Taylor
GREENE ending up on opposite sides of anything
is certainly a sign that that splintering is
taking place. The important thing for the left is,
you know, I have never pushed for this false
unity of the left. There is room for diverse
views on the left, and there are also things that
just aren't actually left. And so we shouldn't
pretend that they are. It's not about false unity.
But right now, the left actually is quite united.
These voices that I've always said are relatively
small in terms of power. They're very loud,
but they're relatively small that do the purity
tests and the litmus tests. They are not getting
nearly the attention that they once did. And
overall, the left is pretty damn united right
now. I think that it's critical at a time when the
right is splintering and some splintering and some
splintering. Ad infinitum. Hopefully that the
left maintain focused on the big issues that we
are trying to deal with. That includes getting
people health care, dealing with inequality,
health, climate. There's so many I don't even
know what order to go. The education crises,
the foreign policy embarrassments that
plagued us under Trump. On and on and
on. The left has an opportunity to, in
contrast to what's happening on the right,
look quite organized and sane and united
and allow the right to continue destroying
itself. Meanwhile, Republicans continue to
just do self-inflicted damage. And I want
to talk about the new anti museum anti book
positions that are surfacing on the right.